So tell me about yourself,
Frederick.
Well, I still wet the bed.
And sometimes I brown it too.
There'll be plenty of times
to work out the kinks, my dear.
Yes. Our whole lives.
Yay.
Can I say,
I adore young couples in love.
- And our readers will too.
- Well, then.
I'm sure they will also
love reading the biggest damn
merger marriage in history.
His steel and my magnets.
That's goddamn science.
Commie, you old tit.
[laughter]
[grunting]
(Harold) When I started,
I was a simple fur trapper.
Look at me now.
My son will be married
into the most powerful family
on the Eastern Seaboard.
Never again will they say,
"You won't amount to anything,
Harold Bellawitcz."
I mean, Bellacourt.
Someday, Celery,
that will be you and I.
[upbeat percussive music]